it's been a week but we
back ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
podcast
[Music]
G with G with g
yeah welcome back to riin with Griffin
this is your
host Eric Griffin I'm back took a week
off cuz I was too busy but I'm back
again let's catch up with the NBA
today that crazy Diddy
lawsuit plus news and notes from around
the web but once again I'm so happy to
be back and thank you for all my loyal
followers and listeners and viewers I
appreciate you so you know how it
[Music]
is riffing with
Griffin um welcome back to Griffin with
Griffin I'm your host Eric Griffin I
think I look a little pink I did
something with the color I don't like it
but whatever it is what it is guys
welcome back uh you know how we do make
sure you subscribe hit the notification
button so you know what's going on uh
with the show appreciate that you know
I'm on Twitch uh daily so make sure you
excuse me check out the twitch because I
be
twitching and you know I don't know
patreon if you want to you know YouTube
member patreon
member uh twitch subscriber helps
support to
show uh so I appreciate all of
that so welcome back riin with Griffin
we are here um you
know last week I had to I was I actually
I was directing another comedy special
shout out to Martin amini comedy
special um you know so I had to go out
to DC on Wednesday when I usually do
this live and then to the night before I
was busy with stuff you know Rachel's
pregnant and so there just so much going
on right now I just there was no way for
me to get another episode in listen I'm
going to have a special video up on
YouTube because I want to talk my one of
my new sponsors right now well old new
sponsors ewin racing so they got I got
this new chair I'm going make a little
video short and to put on Instagram look
it's got a a metallic I mean a a what do
you call that a magnetic pillow that you
could put in different places great
lumbar support you know what I mean it's
like this is a great share and they have
it a Black Friday sale so I don't NE I
don't have the code and all that stuff
ready but you know even if you just want
to go to their website ewin racing great
company shout out to them uh for
centimet chair you know but we are back
so yeah so I went out to DC shout out to
Martin amini uh really you know great
dude he is a just a tremendous human
being so look out for him and he's just
been out here selling out you know he's
half Bolivian half Iranian so he's got a
really like interesting mix interesting
story and he's just fun to be around you
could genuinely tell he's like a you
know a good person when he's on stage so
just like you know look out for that man
um let me go to my Instagram
uh let's see is this going to show up
right I think it will so if I go to this
you can see yeah there we
go so there's Martin me we we I did
another you know another special
recording there I am with Evan the DP I
love working with him I've worked with
him now three times now uh but yeah you
know I was back there doing my director
thing again you know there's uh his that
his lovely wife in the middle there
that's uh it was just a fun time you
know and we it was a beautiful theater
at the Lincoln Theater I think Chappelle
shot one of his spe two of his specials
there I think Chappelle shot there CU
he's from uh what do you call he's from
um you know he's from DC also so yeah
good stuff man so uh yeah that was fun
times out there in uh DC so you know
look out for that one not sure that that
one was like you know these kids today
man they doing it right I mean he this
was like independently shot man I mean
can you believe that you know it's like
what like I you know when when I was
coming up you would never think to do
that and we probably should have you
know we probably should have been like
no man we need to be doing this stuff
ourselves but you just didn't think it
was possible you know back when I was
coming up we thought we needed these
networks we thought we needed these
people to like tell us what to do and
like you know what I mean and it's
just it just it doesn't really
necessarily work like that no you could
do this yourself get out there produce I
mean I mean the equipment is better it's
it's cheaper to make things and you know
you just get the right crew and there
was a great crew out there in uh DC
great like local crew because that's the
thing too when you go to different
cities there's like you know so many uh
filmmakers and you know camera guys and
you know crew type guys that are like
trying to fix stuff up and it it was
just like it was pretty interesting man
it was an interesting experience and I'm
learning you know it's like I just you
know I'm no uh seasoned director you
know I've been on many sets for many
years um I've you know I've dabbled in
it you right you know you're doing like
you're doing sketches with friends and
things like that but like to actually be
fullon in charge of all this I'm
learning a lot and I'm learning on the
Fly you know so but I trust myself I
trust my instincts you know I'm great
with especially with young younger
Comics who like you know just to help
them hone in their voice so you know
it's um it was uh it was pretty pretty
fun it's pretty fun experience to uh to
do that man so shout out to everybody
involved in that especially Martin you
know what I mean
he's you know what I mean he's he's
doing it I hope it's still live I'm
having like an issue with my computer I
can't see I can't see the stream so let
me just quickly go to
to let me just I know this is like
always something you know it's been a
week and I forgot about all the nonsense
this that goes on with this you know
with doing this so let me just see if
it's
like you know let me go to my channel
make sure we still let me make sure we
still live in full effect here uh let me
just turn this down in my phone I have
to watch a ad on my own phone on my
podcast that's kind of weird yep I still
see myself I'm doing good
all right so I'm G keep my phone open
like this so I can see the chat if
anybody has anything in chat because
like my website the the I don't know
what's going on here but this is just
like not
refreshing uh I don't know what oh here
we go there it is all right so anyways
um what else is going on W Rachel is
we're getting there man we are she's I
think a little over like I think 30
weeks I think we're at 30 weeks you know
it's amazing how fast it goes uh you
know she's you know back is hurting like
I have to rub her back a lot and just
preparing we got our oh I should oh I
should have taken pictures of the
nursery so we have like our little
nursery set up which is exciting got the
crib set
up and we're still working on that every
day I'm putting something up you I'm
trying to clean you know you have to
just kind of like clean up too and get
rid of things you don't really need
anymore just to like make room and make
space and make life easier so we're in
that process uh right now of doing all
that like if you see my off my office is
a
mess so I got to clean it that's why I
haven't really had a guest come to the
house uh just cuz I my chairs are all
off to the side I mean it's just a whole
big mess man but you know it's I mean
I'm really excited about it I'm really
looking forward to it again I'm still
nervous but I'm excited we went to uh
get the ultrasound and like you know we
saw the nose we you know we're looking
at his nose and her and I are arguing
like whose NOS it is it's so funny you
know one of the things you Rachel says
something that's so funny to me like you
know once you um you know when you're
having a kid you worry like you're like
it's a baby you want your baby to be
cute right we all want our baby to be
cute you think about it it's one of
those things people don't talk about out
loud but I don't give a anyways you know
that's why I say to Rachel like yeah I
hope we have a cute baby you know and
then she goes well you know if I was
worried about a cute baby I would have
got with a model I was like damn what
you oh so I'mma be the reason why the
baby's
[Laughter]
ugly she said it with such a straight
face I was like how dare you woman how
dare
you so you know it is what it is um I
got a Q&A up in the chat for the live
Chatters on YouTube thanks for being
here and for you guys listening later on
uh wherever you listen to your podcast
thanks for listening I love when people
come up to me and they're like hey man
what's up I listen to your podcast or
you know or people send me messages like
like truck drivers love to send me
messages so if you out there on the road
right now be safe out there and thanks
for what you do okay let's go to some
comments let's go to the comment
sections like we do every single week uh
JD bush people still watching that movie
review with Bobby and Steve it's it's
still one of my most viewed videos every
single week it's crazy uh say he says
everyone got me rolling you know um G
maryia Mary something or other whatever
her name is but anyway she just says
really going to miss you on the David
Arnold episode yes and you know rip to
my buddy David Arnold that was tragic
and I hope his family's doing well but
that episode's still up if you want to
see the kind of person he was good guy
really funny to be around um
again uh another comment on
that uh
um let's see somebody's comment again
somebody's commented on the Matt R
special oh by the way shout out to that
for Matt R special number one in the
world it was number one in the world
number one in so many countries I have I
I heard some little inside information
just he's is doing really good so I'm
proud of that you know little bit of
controversy going on because you know
you know he's a straight white male and
he likes to talk about edgy stuff or he
likes to like push the envelope you know
he likes to say you know and it's just
jokes right and so here's a voice of
this Young Generation who is just like
hey can we just get back to Comedy can
we can we get back to like like not
worrying about everybody's feelings at
all times you know especially in a world
where you could just turn the channel
you know what I mean like there's so
many things you can watch think of all
the streaming services and how many
things they have on the streaming
services you if you don't like some and
their comedy you just move on with your
life imagine with the like hundreds of
thousands probably millions of things
you could watch you want to find a thing
that doesn't speak to you that you want
to hate on and then you're going to
focus on that it like it baffles the
mind you know it really does but you
know everybody clout chases in their own
little way even all the little idiots
who make like little like uh response
videos you know they're making their
little like oh I watch this special and
this is what I think you know it's like
[__] nobody cares even the people
watching your thing or looking at you
like what what what who why you why you
worrying about this it's like there's no
award I think people think there's some
sort of clout chasing award show at the
end of the year or like there's some
sort of like and the good person award
goes to you know Bumble head 75 out of
Wyoming who said this special isn't
funny because of this you know like
there's no award show literally nobody
gives a [__] look at me nobody gives a
[__] so just go watch the things that
you like and go spread positivity like
go out there watch something you like
and then comment on it you know what I
like to do and I've said this before if
I I like to listen to audiobooks so when
I listen to an audio book and I love the
Audi book so one I'll I'll hit up the
author love your work thank you so much
and then I'll hit up the voice actor
because they get no love I'll I'll find
them on internet you Twitter whatever
and I'll be like yo loved you in this
book and they're always like oh my God
thank you because how often do people
say that you know as a you know you know
what I mean so like how about this you
want to go hate on somebody because I
know that's fun too like honestly it's
fun I mean podcast or about that you
know what I mean I'm not going to you
want to hate how about this hate but
then go give for every hate go give five
positive comment someplace let's try
that can we try that if you go hate on
something then go find five posit go
give some positivity as well how about
that
okay
um let's see so this Detroit guy said
this is exactly what I'm talking
about this guy comes to my page he goes
not a fan of Griffin seems like only his
opinion is always correct Steve is
totally open to other people's
opinions
uh I'm just gonna let that one
go
[Laughter]
uh oh my God you know it's so funny like
it's like Steve and I when we do the
podcast we talk about it ahead of time
time and he always tells me like Steve
will be like Yo dude let's do a movie
review and it's like you know let's do
that thing that we do like you know
we're arguing we're going back and forth
that's the whole point of it and then
there's like
morons that come to it and go oh man why
are you
arguing why do you think you're right I
mean it's part of the thing man like
what an idiot you are that you don't
know that you know what I mean y'all
think that whatever
um let's see what are we talking about
here okay I don't think you should start
Banning things people should have their
choice eventually they' ban everything
besides running on a hamster wheel to
provide energy I understand that uh bit
stacker you know he says you you know
you you don't you shouldn't start
Banning things okay I'm with you because
he's talking about like they want to ban
smoking okay here's the thing though man
I don't I think that this it's more
nuanced than that like smoke smoking is
an industry a capitalistic industry
they're just to make money they don't
care about health and safety of anyone
like just because something is available
doesn't mean it it just because
something can be produced and and
manufactured and sold doesn't mean it
should be you
know uh if if if you look at the the
health risks of smoking and how about
the financial burden on the whole whole
just in the United States the financial
burden of smoking what it causes lung
cancer and all the things that it causes
that's different from say like oh let's
ban you know something that people don't
like I mean this is like I you know it
it's like they no matter how much they
tax it you know people it's an addictive
drug nicotine you know so then if by
that standard then like you know why are
we worried about fentol and cocaine and
whatever else like destroys lives and or
or or when they were selling o Oxy
Cotton should we not have banned that
you know but it was all you know you
have to remember that the money that was
involved in too like the capitalistic
undertone of everything you know it's
like well if we could sell this we can
make a bunch of money and nobody thinks
about but if we sell this people are
going to die people are going to you
know I always use that oxycoton as a
baseline for like anything is possible
the fact that doctors were [__]
prescribing this to people because they
were getting Kickbacks and the money
that was involved in everything and
keeping people drugged up I mean just
think about how crazy that is is that
something we should have banned yeah I
mean smoking is something that like has
been going on for so long that we kind
of think that that's our god-given right
to get lung cancer you know we think
like that but but if you if you think
way back one they didn't know how bad it
was for you now that we do know how bad
it is for you there's a part of us that
should be like yeah we shouldn't sell
this anymore it should really be an
illegal substance right right if we
think about it but it's just been around
for so long that we go ah you know now
that we're finally Banning it you can't
attach that to like you know the
government is doing too much I mean just
just look at the history of it that [__]
got to go get rid of smoking get rid of
tobacco nicotine get rid of
it
anyway so this the same guy has like 50
different comments he said if you looked
at the the Lucid stock price as a
company collapsing eh company's come and
go like that the company actually like
this the you
know the company's in flux because
they're trying to figure out how to sell
the car affordable car in uh you know to
the masses right but like it's a company
that's mostly owned by Saudi Arabia now
Saudi Arabia has a huge stake in the
company they just built a multi-billion
dollar facility in Saudi Arabia to make
the cars and then so so they have a
second location to to to for Europe and
all that kind of stuff they're not going
to let the this company fail just yet um
you know they they're they're invested
in like showing that they care about
green you know like there's a bunch of
Arab countries who are like I thought I
think Abu Dhabi was talking about
building a green City you know that's
like totally run on solar and uh you
know getting away from fossil fuels I
mean they're aware of it you know it's
weird that we need to be doing the same
thing like I never understand why it's
like not solar panels everywhere every
house every apartment building every
business solar panels should be on
everything uh it should be running the
grid we should have whatever those like
batteries that they use to like so use
power at night we should be sharing
power there should be no way there
should be never have a power issue you
know it's crazy but anyways so yeah I
know what you're saying Lucid is up and
down but that's what happens with a
company like that but you know it
doesn't that has nothing to do with how
beautiful F and awesome the car is
though you know what I mean uh how they
run in their company in a bus it has
nothing to do with the car itself my car
is dope this is
such I love this car love it
anyways uh what else we got and that's I
think that's good enough for uh I think
that's good enough for the comments
today oh you know what let me go to the
quick Q&A section of the thing see what
people have to
say
uh let's see is it is it fair that Jenny
Orga is not returning for Scream s
because of comments on social media n
that's not true I don't believe that um
you you startop looking at too much
nonsense
um let's see what else we got here
what's up Griff Niagara Falls Rainbow
Bridge car explosion was an attempted
terror attack oh wow really I have to
take a look at that I mean you know
there's always going to be crazy people
out here man you know not every you you
know not every place in the world wants
peace most places just you know have
their own agenda I mean even the United
States really you know but you know we
fight for the peace within our borders
we at least want to be able to just live
our regular lives listen to podcasts go
to movies you know work take care of our
kids go to this the park we just want to
feel safe that we could do that and I
and I think that I think ultimately we
want that all over the world but it
doesn't seem that people all over the
world want that cuz you hear about
things going on in other places in the
world and you just go damn this is like
you guys are not you don't you just want
to you just want to conquer and own and
and uh have your own way of life and
it's like damn I don't know I mean not
to say that we're not the same way but
you know that's why we fight for ours
you know that's why we make sure we have
our borders and we you know we have our
military to make sure hey this is how we
want to live and if you don't like it
too bad you know but it's like it sucks
there are people out there who are
really trying to like stop that you know
so and victims of these kinds of things
I I I I pray for the families you know
what I
mean um let's see what else we got
here I know somebody said what's with
all the directing being done here in DC
well it's just a coinci coincidence you
know like Matt he love he I I think he's
GNA move to to Virginia I think he's
going to move to that area he loves that
area and Martin amini is from DC so
that's the reason why I was in DC but
it's just a coinky
dinky
um somebody said did mat rif get a cut
of the helmet
sales so if you don't know about that so
you know Matt's getting a lot of flak
for like some of the content in his
special but like you know he's like he
he put up a post that said this is my
official apology and he and there was a
link and the link was to special needs
helmet
so you freaking doubled down on that I
mean I feel it man I think that there
was young people out there in his age
range I think there's people in Middle
America that look at him and they go oh
I you know oh what this handsome guy you
know good-looking white guy and they
think you know they think well can he I
like I want to see him be funny can he
just be funny like it's not a crime to
be white it's not a crime to be a male
it's not a crime to do comedy
edgy comedy even and even the kind of
Comedy where you know somebody's the
butt of the joke that that you think oh
we should never make jokes about that
whatever there's a voice he's a voice
for those people who just like yeah that
guy looks like me or or I like this guy
and I think that that there it's it's
harmless and I think that that's coming
back I mean we've pushed so far the
pendulum has been swinging so far with
this like you know where it's like we
got to oh my God tox toxic masculinity
and you know we have to get rid of all
male things we don't want to see any
white males on TV that kind of push they
were making it's like what are you
talking about what are you talking about
you know GH
whatever all right let's get back to
it um what do I want to talk about
first um we are we actually are making a
rif tour documentary for somebody in
chat that just said that um I'm actually
directing a documentary about him right
now so anyways let's go with let's just
go with the big news so did y'all see
this thing
about Diddy you know he's got you know
he's got he's in like hot water man and
so his
exgirlfriend you know accused
him of she's accusing the hip-hop
Mainstay of rap decade long pattern
She's accused him of
abuse sex trafficking human trafficking
sexual battery sexual assault and gender
motivated violence among other causes of
action this is a a lawsuit that she
filed a civil lawsuit that she filed
against
him um and like she's saying that he had
complete control over his life and cars
I mean it was just it just goes on and
on and on and on and
on so so you know what are you supposed
to do so it's a civil lawsuit according
to reports this isn't about the lawsuit
it's just what she was asking for he's
saying that she was trying to extort him
that she's saying I'm going to have a
tell all book or you have or pay me $30
million I'm telling everybody everything
about you and I think that what happened
was they they were they G they got to a
game of chicken you know where it was
like he was like do it then you know and
then then she was like fine you know and
then like here's here's my thoughts
about this okay I don't think she has
any proof of any of this okay because if
she did your first call is to the police
right because a criminal case would for
sure help her civil case but I don't
know maybe there's lawyers out there
help me out here okay help me out if
you're a lawyer maybe you can help me
with understanding I do understand that
you know civil damages versus a criminal
case they are different cases and the
burden of evidence and proof doesn't
have to be as high and it's the same
reason why OJ
Simpson he was not convicted of the
criminal case but he then was convicted
in the Civil Trial he had to pay in the
Civil Trial right so I think it's the
same kind of thing with this you know
now when somebody settles for a case it
it we really got to stop thinking
thinking that it means they're
guilty it's not the case it's not always
the case who knows in this situation but
I'm saying we shouldn't as people
watching jump to that conclusion I mean
there's a lot of reasons why people
would settle a case like this I mean the
main reason is just embarrassment let's
say he P he goes forward with this case
and they have to go to court remember
the Johnny Depp uh amber herd trial all
of the stuff that they had to come out
with like she had to in court and and
and and like we have to hear that she's
[__] in the bed he had to come out and
be like you know yeah I'm a drunk I'm a
drug user uh yeah I've done this this
this and that but I didn't abuse her I
mean like all of the embarrassing
details that have to come
out just think about what your partner
knows about you uh what even if just
forget the criminal SE just think of
some things that your partner knows
about you things that you've done done
sexually or things you've said or
whatever you've done with your partner
and imagine having to go talk about that
in court I mean so I understand so that
sometimes it's because of embarrassment
people just go I'm not going I don't
want to go to that's just settle you
know but a lot of times you know so I
understand that so I think they gave to
a head and then because it went away
like this now my question is this is
that Justice you know what I mean is it
justice like if he really did do all of
these terrible terrible things you me to
tell me that because he has money he
could just pay and get off with it and
then you're okay with that and then all
the the the women out there who are like
go girl you got it like you know good
for you for standing up for yourself
it's like first of all not every uh
criminal or the as salent or what
whatever the word is the person on Diddy
side that doing committing the crimes
most of those people aren't millionaires
so think of all the women out there who
are not getting Justice they can't you
they're not they're not going to satis
be satisfied with like oh let me Sue
here's a civil Tri let me Sue the guy
from the down the street who has nothing
yay justice so like the system needs to
be reworked in that way for sure and
then from TMZ reports because I've been
following this she didn't file any
charges at all like TMZ found from the
uh from her on about this trial there
was no you know
nothing so I have a friend of mine I
talk to my friends you know and they
immediately jump to oh statute
limitations you know what I mean well
maybe here's the thing though wouldn't
that help the Civil Trial so let's say
all of these things that he's being
accused of go under like well you have
to file these charges within however
many years whatever which I think is
ridiculous for some of these things it
shouldn't be statue limitations on human
trafficking right so I don't believe
that but that's just one of those
[__] things ignorant people say
about these cases because they don't
really know any better you know but my
thing is this wouldn't it help the tri
the her case like if she went to the
police tried to file these charges and
then she had proof that the police said
listen we can't file these you can't
file these charges because it's statute
Limited
then wouldn't that help her civil case
so then when she goes to court she could
be like I tried to file charges I didn't
do it he was a powerful man I was scared
I'm in a better position in my life now
I have support and I really need to get
this out I tried and they said no now
I'm going to do the civil case to me it
would help her
case right I don't know you tell me you
tell me in the comments so I don't get
it so so she you know so then she files
the C the the trial the thing two days
later I think a day later they've
settled of course it's an NDA we'll
never know how much money she got but I
tell you this I don't think it was
anywhere near $30 million you know it's
just not how that works you can ask for
whatever you want but you end up not
getting you end up not getting uh you
know that amount of money so as I go to
this like we there's this great web
there's a website for it you know I mean
vulture has a whole thing about it what
was Diddy accused of in the lawsuit the
lawsuit alleges several instances of
abuse abuse rap battery force sex acts
with male sex workers uh then she
depicts the Mogul as
uh a textbook abuser and and
and so many things in this in this case
that you know she's accusing of of
him so then you go down what do we know
about the settlement the two parties did
not disclose terms of the settlement
which came just one day after Cassie
filed the lawsuit I
mean it don't make him look good it
don't make her look good so I don't
think justice has served in this
situation you know I I feel like I feel
like we're doing a disservice to women
who have been abused and are afraid to
come out we have to find a way to
protect these people these are victims
real victims out there don't get to do
what this lady did like real there
there's victims out there who need some
protection they need to be able to go
get everything out and there needs to be
an investigation that is not public to
me that's what messes things up like
this idea that everything's got to go on
social media everything's got to I mean
that's the sucky part I think there's
got to be some kind of gag order to
protect both parties I think women
should be able to like just go in and be
like look this is what happened and then
they could be like all right right well
we'll do some sort of preliminary uh
investigation to see what's going on to
help people because most victims don't
have this situation and then they're
afraid they don't want to they don't
want to talk they don't want to say
anything they get vilified they get told
that they're not you know they're lying
and it's like and you get why because in
this situation this seems like a cash
grab just on the surface of it okay
whether she is right whether everything
she's saying is true or not it looks
like she don't care about Justice she
just care about getting her bag that
perception to me is not good for people
who are out there who are not highlevel
A-list victims and you know perpetrators
you know what I'm
saying so the civil lawsuit was brought
under the adult supervisors act that
gives victims of sexual abuse who were
18 or older at the time of the alleged
abuse oneyear window to bring cases in
New York after any statutes limitations
have expired so see I don't understand
that you know so so there is a thing
there about this I think that should be
put out there right I think it should be
like we should know that she actually
went to the police and she couldn't get
justice that she wanted so now she's
doing this I just think for the
narrative and the story that seems to be
it would it would I think it would help
her you know it would make him be like
all right what do you want how much
money you want you know what I
mean uh
Cassie told the times in on November
16th it became clear that this was an
opportunity to speak up about the trauma
I have experience that I will be
recovering from for the rest of my life
Cassie filing mentions the law as thanks
to the passage of the act in New York
and California she's now ready and able
to also confront her abuser and to hold
him and those who enabled his abuse
accountable for their actions so I don't
know it seems like there's some sort of
laws or something that's going on in
there I think we need to hear more about
those kinds of things because I don't
want her to be like if she's a real
victim and all these things happen to
her and this is her only course of
action to get some sort of Justice even
if it's monetary to to hurt him to get
back at him I think that that needs to
be laid out clear for all of us so other
victims can take the same route because
look he got hundreds of millions of
dollars but somebody that only got
$30,000 hey if you took 10 if you took
20,000 from him that might hurt that
person more than It's Gonna Hurt Diddy I
don't know you know what I'm saying but
either way either way I just think that
this system needs to be reworked you
know so I don't know it's just it's it's
very like you know it's like when you
start talking about these things you
know people jump to like conclusions and
like you know people you know it becomes
a thing where it's like you know there's
two sides it's like believe all women at
all times and then it's like if you if
you're a guy and you go this seems weird
it seems like she's just going for money
then all of a sudden you don't care
about victims and you're like you know
that's the that's the like that's where
people jump to because you know it's
like the most the most idiot part of
people's brains are what they use for
social media most of the time you know
it's just the most superficial dumb part
of their brain there's no Nuance there's
no discussion there's no like hey let's
look this up let's find the facts let's
figure this out let's see like you know
what I mean that never usually happens
in these kinds of situations so but this
just was like a very weird case and to
me I don't think Justice was served but
there may be some lawyers out there who
going to be like well actually cuz you
know when you ever talk to a lawyer and
you hear about like you hear about the
law law and you're like oh wow I didn't
know that that was a thing it's like
very detailed like you know due process
is important like you know the the the
justice system you know yes it feels as
if when you have money to justice system
works better for you but there are a lot
of like there's a lot of laws and things
in place place in the justice system to
help people and to like you know what
you can accuse people of Rights and all
that kind of stuff so it's like we
shouldn't when these kind of things come
out like this we should try our best as
individuals hey let's look this up and
see what's going on here so we can get a
better understanding you know for for
other people as opposed to just like
everybody's just fighting on the
internet you know what I
mean so who
knows uh but I know but somebody's
saying like it's probably like like like
I'm going give this is this is look this
is why I don't think she got a lot of
money I think she got some money right
and then after lawyers the lawyers take
33% you know you and you don't get taxed
for uh cases like you don't get I I
believe the law is you don't get taxed
on settlements but you know the taxes
the lawyers take all the money but if
you go back to Colin
Kaepernick and I should actually look
this up
um you know uh what was it
Colin
Kaepernick uh yeah here we go okay Colin
Kaepernick settlement
amount because he broke somebody broke
the
NDA
[Music]
um let's see what was it
now I think it was like oh here we go
here it is right
here okay so all right I'm sorry for
people listening you're probably like
Griffin stop mumbling get to the point I
just needed to find it on the internet
so all right so here's Colin Kaepernick
who believed he was blackballed by the
NFL which he probably was it seems as if
he was you know everything that he did
everything he he did the the NFL was
like no man we don't want you around
anymore which to me is still right you
know but he sued him you know and you
think that here's a 12 billion
organization and this guy is suing
because he's he can't work anymore and
he thinks that just collusion and he was
you know and you go wow well
quarterbacks are making $30 million a
year at the time 30 $40 million so you
go here's a 12 million organization he
is
suing uh you know he's suing them for
he's what do you think he's going to sue
for I would have had a four or fiveyear
career I would have made $40 million a
year so he was probably suing trying to
get 40 50 60100 million from the NFL you
would think like that's what he was
asking for initially it was he was
initially asking for a large amount of
money turns out it came
out it got out that he got he got less
than $10
million so I was like oh okay so that's
what I'm saying about this case she may
have put out there whoever side put out
that she was asking for $30 million
trust me she didn't get $30
million you know what I mean she
probably got like way
way less than that and then but it's
like that's free money so it's like okay
give me that money but we'll
see we shall see how that because I
don't think she wanted to go to court or
him I don't think she had enough I don't
think there's what could she have proven
because to me if she could prove some of
these things there'd be like an official
now he I believe that there is some
official investigations going on but I
don't think it's Rel related to this
case I think he got a lot of stuff going
on you know so well we might see him in
the news and I think this was a bad
precedent too because now people can say
whatever outlandish things they want and
is he gonna just settle you know this
happens a lot by the way especially with
professional athletes it happens more
than you think man I knew a few I know a
few professional athletes and this is
the thing that happens they go to a bar
there's like a scuffle or or something
happens next thing you know a girl is
saying I was abused by this guy and the
lawyers go listen
man going to court is going to cost you
whatever it is the Emar whatever just
pay this chick $100,000 and let's get
out and that's what happens a lot of
times that's why they have these classes
and courses but these professional
athlet athletes like don't go to clubs
and bars don't go to places where you
don't know people keep a team around you
and all that make sure there's Witnesses
and all this kind of stuff but you know
this kind of stuff happens all the time
you know so
it just it getss muddled because then
when somebody truly gets abused and
victimized when somebody's really you
know in a bad situation now it's like
what's the burden of proof you know
sucks
anyways all right y'all where are we um
oh [__] didn't want to do that had
Escape so let's go to something let's go
to my topics of the day I have some like
there's some weird topic topics let's
talk about some more light-hearted stuff
here um
so I love when this kind of stuff comes
out study says eating pasta does not
lead to weight gain I mean thank
you you know what I mean it's like this
is the kind of thing our our whole lives
we're being told you can't eat stuff
don't eat carbs don't eat carbs don't
eat carbs you know stay away from this
this is G you know that's a fatty meal
whatever and then there's a study 20
years later and here it is study says
eating pasta does not lead to weight
gain so you're like well what what can
we believe now what you know what what
what I keep waiting for I want the study
to come out that says broccoli is
terrible for you you know then we could
be like I knew it you know but it's like
when this kind of stuff comes out you
just go is this misinformation you just
feel like nothing is real you know and
this is from puberty great site love
this site a comprehensive study by
scientist Lisa Sanders and Joanne Salva
reveals that regular pasta consumption
isn't associated with increased body
weight despite its reputation as refined
carbs pasta's rich in nutrients can
contribute to weight management when
part of a balanced
diet I'm going to get some past
today thank you let's keep going so that
one was just weird to me just cuz I'm
like you know they this that kind of
stuff always comes
out this was just
hilarious dude the fact that they have a
place called come and
go Iowa man gets indecent exposure
charge after getting caught pleasuring
himself at a comeand Go gas station I
mean with this story just you know this
what more what more do we need to say
about this
right I mean the guy's like yo I'm at
the come and go you know this is what
you this is what you do at the come and
go man like why why y'all he's like why
y'all tripping man you know when you
have to come and go you come and go
was
like I don't know
man I mean imagine like that's what you
say in
court you know you know you were in
court like sir it was a it was a come
and go so I decided to come and
go I mean imagine getting arrest just
imagine even just getting arrested at a
come and go I don't know I've never been
somebody that has wanted to have you has
anybody in chat want to admit to like
have you masturbated in public public or
like a ba airplane bathroom or have you
just been like I got to get this out and
so you just do it I mean I don't know it
see it seems weird this is just look at
that guy he looked like a come and go
guy right why why when it's like
something bad happens to someone why do
they have to have the worst picture
possible of the person like where do
they find these pictures man ah poor guy
this one is just there are still people
spending money on dumb [__] out there
there's a 33-year-old pet psychic who
charges
$550 an hour no it's $550 for a
90minut reading of their
dog and there's a weight list of 7.6
th000 people like kudos to you baby
girl it's a
dog okay it's a damn
dog that's all I have to
say this chick is spent getting
$550 to pretend to understand what's
going on
in with the dog like us like like to
pretend to do
magic idiots are paying this woman
$550 like you're crazy like what is it
what is a psychic reading um I'm
hearing I'm hearing a name I'm feeling a
name it is it
is
oh Bobo I hear Bobo is it Bobo you know
what I mean it's like what what are we
what are we talking about a psychic
reading of
dogs Jesus man this was this was the
absolute dumbest craziest story of all
my stories this
week now this I thought was very
fascinating and this goes back to what I
was talking about earlier Portugal just
ran on 100% renewable energy for six
days in a row this is possible man and
we need to be doing this all over the
United States man there's so much wind
technology in the middle of the country
there's so many hot places to set up
solar panels I mean let's get off
of freaking fossil fuels and let's get
to this renewable energy it's a smaller
country they only have 10 million people
so it's probably easier for them to do
this as opposed to you know we got over
we have 400 million citizens and a
across a vast amount 3,000 square you
know however much our are are
uh square miles or whatever however you
measure it so you know this is tough but
I think it's doable I think it's doable
and I hope that we're going in this
direction you know little places like
this we got to be like man this we got
to take it take their lead you know so
uh when I buy a house I just that's one
of the things I want is just to have
like solar panels and all those like you
know whatever the all that stuff that
they do you know you ever think about
living off the grid you know like well
in your own water and all that kind of
stuff I don't know if I'm that guy I'm
kind of a city boy but I believe in this
I believe in like using the fossil fuels
for other things CU like on the East
Coast we're in the west coast so it's
easy to like we don't we use our AC you
know it's not like we have to have it
like you know we don't have to have our
AC at 50 to you know because it's so hot
you in in like hot places or you know
where it's really cold we have to have
the heat on at like 90 or what you know
I'm saying like there's like
levels it's easier on in hot you know
places but like they still got to burn a
lot of fossil fuels and whatever in for
the east coast to keep them warm in the
winter maybe we should be pumping all
that energy from the middle of the
country all that wind and turbine energy
that we can use I've heard I've heard
reports and scientists talk about that
we could we could you know light up the
whole East Coast with energy from the
middle like they should be sending us
water and we should be sending them
energy I think work out like that but
you know when you get money involved
things get messed up all right this
story and I talked about this on Golden
hour with the boys because I told him
about this but this is just crazy to me
a jackpot winner sues his child's mother
for telling his family about the win
what I listen if you sign an NDA with
your baby
mama you know and you just won by the
way the do won a billion dollars all
right he won a billion dollars and he
took the payment of
$726 million after
taxes $72 something million dollars to
do one he going to his baby mama
look I'd wanton a lotto girl and I want
to take care of my kid and I'm GNA take
care of you don't tell nobody well don't
tell my family well like are you going
to still live in your apartment how are
you going to keep it a
secret I like you just not going to see
your family are you going like was the
guy going to get like a old beat up
Honda Accord and like rent a old keep
his same beat up house or whatever he
had and just anytime he messes with his
family he drives the Accord and he goes
to the house like oh he guys oh God get
struggling you know it's tough here
really tough and then when they leave he
[__] helicopters over to his freaking
nine-bedroom mansion that he owns now
like what a piece of [__] man you had
nothing this guy you would have never
got a billion dollars in your life take
care of your family you you know yeah
you got a piece so what you got a piece
of [__] family so what break them off a
little bit you know what you do you get
like a little family fund you take $10
million you put it into some sort of
like annuity account right that earns
interest and it pays out a dividend
payment to your family where it's like
all right look yall going to get 5,000 a
week for 20 years or something like that
you know where you can figure it out and
hey that's it that's all the money you
want that you gon to get from me
something you can set up some kind of
thing where you take care your family
like you had nothing before this I just
don't understand why he would and then
he's going to sue his his baby mama he
gonna sue her like this guy is a piece
of [__] in my opinion piece of [__] dude
just be like ah you told him
ah how about this you're such a piece of
[__] just be a piece of [__] family
calls yo man you wanton a
lottery we're sorry the number you
dialed doesn't want to talk to you you
know what I'm saying you have a security
guard now you move you change your
number you move someplace else you take
the baby mama and the kid and go hey we
moving she's like well I don't want to
move you want to live in a $25 million
house pack your [__] [__] we leaving
you know what I'm saying and then she'd
be like okay you know what I'm saying
they move to an island whatever he said
you living over there I'm going live
this one over here I just want to see my
kid our backyards be connected you have
your life I have my life and then your
family will never find you you don't
have to worry about it you know what I'm
saying like it's like they just seems so
ridiculous to
me I don't know this just a weird story
to me in my opinion oops and the last
one was
this um this woman who married herself
and later cheated on
herself what
what are any of us shocked that she's
white I mean I don't want to be that
guy but if you're listening you don't
see the picture when you heard this the
woman who married herself and later
cheated on
herself was your first thought oh this a
that sound like a you know a Mexican
girl no of course it's a crazy white
woman what do we what
The Story Goes a woman who married
herself yes you read that correctly back
in 2015 has cheated on herself and she
went on the live television to speak of
her
ordeal 37-year-old Sophia married
herself in
200 I'm not even going to read the rest
of this like you said what what what are
we talking about you married
yourself you married
yourself you just if you married
yourself you in charge you just be like
yeah I'm in an open relationship with me
so you know what I mean you you you know
if it was me I'd be like yeah okay I
married myself and you know and then
Rachel's my side
piece you know what I'm saying I'll be
like gotta take sh you got be quiet cuz
you know me is here and me be tripping
sometimes cuz I'm married to me say what
are we what are we talking about people
are so
stupid
this this is mental illness this is
mental illness man and we got to do
something
about ah last but not least you know I
got a new I got a new iPhone so I'm a
little iffy about it I don't know
anybody else got the new iPhone what do
you think about
it I don't know man just like it's like
how is it different is it better it
feels lighter I I feel like the
charge I I feel like the charge is
freaking not
good you know so so I don't even know
man it's like it's like this is iPhone
15 I think I'm G wait till 17 or
something before I'll buy another one
actually I had a 13 and I didn't get the
14 and I jumped to the 15 but I do like
that it's all USBC now so let's get rid
of lightning and be done with it you
know we got to get rid of the lightning
uh stupid
whatever that stupid technology that
sucked so now we're here with freaking
you know the good the good stuff
man all right
y'all I think we did it you know what
time it is now oh before before I go I
just want to say thanks to everybody for
watching make sure you subscribe hit the
Subscribe button you know I'm on Twitch
most days I got to go to my I'm working
out today so at 2:30 I got to work out
I'm in the West Coast so I got to go my
workout I've been working out guys still
doing it great stuff um and then uh you
know if you want to support on the
patreon make sure you support on the
patreon too so we got the patreon we got
the twitch you know and make sure you
subscribe y'all and I appreciate y'all
for everything that you do when y'all
are here you know what I mean I
appreciate y'all but you know what time
it
is
yeah
it's that rap recap
Time Rap
recap oh oh oh oh
ginin Griffin
[Music]
Griffin and got
charge large and
charge
wo uh yeah so uh
did he with that
lawsuit yeah yeah
yeah you know what I completely forgot
as I'm doing this Happy Thanksgiving
everybody if you've waited this long in
the podcast thanks for being here but
you know what Happy Thanksgiving have a
great time with your with your family I
completely forgot about that that's
tomorrow no it's tomorrow so be thankful
for your family I am thankful for all
you guys that listen and watch the
podcast every single week and leave
comments uh whatever you're thankful for
please put in the comments and I
appreciate you guys for being here every
single week the people that are
listening our truck drivers on the road
people just at work just want some noise
in the background I'm here for you uh
you know get your food uh you know jam
on it with your family um this is going
to be my last Thanksgiving you know next
time next Thanksgiving I'm GNA be a dad
so look out for you guys and I
appreciate you and I will see you next
week he